We normally start
in the dark
and then begin by carving out to bring
the audience's attention to
one thing at a time.
How do you give
physical concrete form
to something as abstract
and nebulous as music
or to an idea?
When I was at
school, my teachers
called me a jack of all
trades, master of none.
The more paths I was offered,
the more I wanted to take.
I wanted to read about
neuroscience and ecopsychology.
I studied English literature,
then art, then stage design.
It's quite unusual to make that
leap from classical theater
into pop music.
And people are constantly
invited to specialize.
And I'm here to teach
you to do the opposite.
This class is for those who want
to turn what is in their mind
into something they
can hold in their hand,
whether it's within the
field you currently work
or specifically within
the field of design.
Iterate, iterate,
iterate, even when
you think you've
arrived at something.
And you might even
just infuriate yourself
into having to come
up with a new idea.
So many artists,
designers, makers--
once you peel away
the surface, you
realize that they're
making in order
to conquer a sense of loss.
And certainly, in
my experience, I
made a decision to throw myself
into my work in my early 20s
because of a loss that
happened in my life.
That energy of creation
as a reaction against loss
is incredibly powerful.
You have never
researched enough.
Your life will be an
endless, and, I hope,
fruitful and happy journey
of not knowing enough.
If you're choosing to watch
this class because you want
to keep expanding the
paths along which you walk,
you're in good company.
I'm Es Devlin, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]